I am so excited.
And you brought this game to the show.
Yes, I did choose this game.
I love that.
I was like anywhere, anytime,
anything Alison wants to do.
And then, I found out you play it
with your beautiful husband, Dave Franco,
who we've been just talking
about the beauty of your relationship.
So now I feel like I'm in the game with you guys.
Well, we'll see if you have his level of athleticism.
Well, I don't, I can promise you that.
But I'm excited and like I'm here to play.
Here's what I'll say about this game.
I feel like they're pitting us against each other
like they would want us to have a winner and a loser,
but the way to make it work is by working together.
Like I have to want to get your ring on my horn.
For me, it's like hos before bros.
I don't compete with women.
To me, we're literally...
How tall is this thing?
Oh, and we have a prize at stake.
Woo!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Okay so the game is each of us get four rings,
and whoever catches the most rings
on their unicorn horn wins.
And if I win, this side of the audience
is gonna go home with a prize.
And if Alison wins, you guys are gonna go home with a prize.
Okay, now I gotta do it for real.
We're playing with each other,
not against each other, but for you guys.
We're playing out of love.
We're playing only out of love, Alison.
And I'm gonna kill that side of the room!
Yeah, yeah!
Alison.
All right, here we go.
You go first.
Yeah?
No, I've gotta go.
You go first.
Okay, you go first.
Okay, oh God.
I'm like, no, I'm just kidding.
Do you want me to move or stay still?
Stay still.
Ah.
Ah!
All right.
(audience cheering)
I leaned in a little bit there.
I kind of think...
Oh!
I chose this game.
Ah, I was trying to help!
But maybe I sabotaged.
No, and you did.
It wasn't going in there anyway.
Oh my God, you guys.
I'm more of like a receiver than a tosser.
Oh.
Harder than it looks.
It is, but I'm so into this game.
We need more rings.
Oh my God!
The crazy thing is I think my side
of the room is gonna win,
because I have the most,
like I have the most rings on my horn.
You have one, you have one!
(audience clapping)
You got one!
I knew it was a bad idea!
I know, but you know what?
We're just so not that show.
We got all of you.
You're all going home with something, that's right.
(audience cheering)
I'm sorry.
The prize is something I'm so into,
I hope you guys are too.
Spin Master Games heard how much we all love games here.
And so they're sending everyone in our audience
home with a $50 gift card to stock your game shelf
with a great game.
(audience cheering)
So thank you, Spin Master.
And thank you for bringing so much fun,
and warmth, and love, and goodness,
and talent, in everything that you do
and put out into the world.
I'm such an uberfan of yours, I have been for so long.
I'm so happy to celebrate you.
Drew, likewise, oh.
Thank you for having me.
"Roar," premiering
this Friday on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back!
(upbeat music)